God from everything who work in New York
and working at a restaurant called craft
and being sort of the first person there
that had no real experience I've worked
at a couple restaurants before that and
I felt like I was a luckiest person in
the world working out at craft because
the staff was awesome and I just felt
like oh my god where's everyone else
like I'm learning so much and from
amazing cooks John Benno's a chef at per
se mark nor Owens hearth and insieme
akhter nawabs you David wise the list
goes on and on and on and almost
everyone that opened up that restaurant
is a chef in America or abroad and it
was a real special time and I just feel
whatever I've done in the industry I
made the right connections or I just you
know it just happened and I don't know I
feel incredibly lucky